I'm an OB Gyna Texas
and a mother of three wonderful children.
Having this beautiful,
messy, chaotic,
but wonderful family,
it's the joy of my life.
I never thought that I would need an abortion
for a planned pregnancy, but I did.
Two years ago,
I became pregnant with a baby I desperately wanted.
At a routine ultrasound,
I Learned that the fetus would have a fatal condition
and that there was absolutely no chance of survival.
In Texas, you are forced to carry that pregnancy,
and that is because of Donald Trump overturning Roe v.
Wade. The choice was completely taken away.
I was to continue my pregnancy,
putting my life at risk.
It's every woman's worst nightmare,
and it was absolutely unbearable.
We need leaders that will protect our rights
and not take them away.
And that's Joe Biden and Kamala Harris.
I'm Joe Biden,
and I approve this message.